[Music]
will you listen to me
that btr is five miles wide and it's
definitely gonna hit us
[Music]
giant space rocks crashing into earth
have long been one of hollywood's go-to
disasters
but now some people will be welcoming
them
in a much smaller and less threatening
form this week
dozens of meteorites in all shapes and
sizes
went up for bid at christie's here in
new york in what's become an
annual auction our deep impact auction
is our annual
auction of meteorites at christie's and
it presents
the very best meteorites available on
the market at this moment
meteorites have been raining down on our
planet since it formed and
serve as our principal source of
material from other worlds
some of those up forbid an iron specimen
with this unusual shape
discovered in namibia expected to fetch
around 80 thousand dollars
it has this beautiful form and shape to
it
that's been carved by celestial and
terrestrial forces over the eons
and it's it originates from an object
that is four and a half billion years
old
and an actual piece of the moon ejected
into space following an
impact on the lunar surface then carved
into a sphere here on earth
estimated price between 300 and 500
thousand dollars
it's just incredible having a piece of
the moon in your hand
really is a magical moment it transports
you to
another world and being able to touch it
just an incredible and humbling
experience
they're all being sold by an auction
house better known for dealing in works
of art
but many see these objects in the same
vein
prized for their beauty and their rarity
since we've been doing these sales since
2014 we have seen corners of the art
market
flock to this category when they
previously weren't aware of it
many of them are beautiful sculptures in
their own right
and i have seen meteorites displayed in
our clients houses alongside antiquities
and contemporary works of art
i want that one i know i want that
beautiful
they are all gorgeous but i still can't
get that picture out of my mind
of the blob coming out of one of those
meteorites
for those who just the blob you know
it's